[Music]
are you
ready this is the main event
the let's get it ready
[Applause]
[Applause]
uh who wants a selfie
tentacular i've got your whole life
story tattooed on my body
yeah in a long history
of monster wrestling there has never
been a champion white quite like
kentucky
fans around the world are asking is
there a challenger out there with the
hunger
the drive the discipline to become the
next
champion
what all right i think that's enough for
today
steve might not look like much but there
is a champion monster inside of him
did he eat thank you
that felt great
we seriously need to work on strength
and endurance fortunately i know just
the thing
what yeah that's going to be a hard no
for me
[Music]
oh boy oh this is my nightmare
[Music]
for thousands of years the bond between
my
children and i was perfect
now a dark presence threatens to destroy
the amazon
you are a very special person you were
called by the spirits
hello where are your spirit guys
you have to save the village
you need to be strong we have to stop
them
it is time for us to be brave
the jungle needs you no rainbow
you are the whole you just need to
believe in yourself
it's me and the jungle now but
even the greatest hunter can use a
little help
[Music]
that's not a hug this is a hug
[Music]
here's to hotel transylvania
johnny works so hard to make this extra
[Music]
special
okay thank you dear son-in-law
i ruined everything johnny what are you
talking about
your dad never really thought of me as
part of the family all because i'm not a
monster
you want to become a monster huh van
helsing
demonstration ray turns humans into
monsters and monsters into humans
what is this safe though great question
that's weird nothing happened
[Music]
the nightmare it's over i'm human again
hey drac what's up johnny oh no
oh drag look at you
now look at me oh no no he got me you're
a human and i'm a monster
it's like freaky friday but on a tuesday
though
what's going on
[Music]
what's up fellas frank oh i'm balding
[Music]
we can go anywhere do anything
we just gotta stick together we
underdogs have to look out for each
other right
underdogs this is gonna be the best
summer ever
[Music]
we'll write down every road
the whole world together
[Music]
it'll be amazing
[Music]
but there's just one thing
wait did you see that no one can find
out
please don't think
where did you boys say you were from
[Music]
who is coming to my birthday party what
about rapunzel
and don't tell me she's getting her hair
done nope
writing something called a book sleeping
beauty says she has insomnia princess
crew
that's a ship sir princess leia she's a
general now i demand glorious guests
then may i suggest inviting this young
lady
finally this horrible crone gets it
once upon a time there lived a princess
named snow white
but this fairy tale is about to get
a whole new twist
we need to find the most beautifulest
woman to kiss us and reverse the curse
what was that it's a witch let's catch
her and make her break the spell
one's where i can see him witch
oh my gosh what what happened to me i
mean my face
and my waist um is that really what i
look like
in the mirror i think i hit her too hard
your power has drained you i don't have
much time prince
find her why are they after you
it's my shoes yeah they're magical
attention idiots draws
oh it's that loser prince average ah voo
raj ah please charge
featuring the voices of chloe grace
morris sam claflin
gina gershon and patrick warburton i
can't wait for you to see the real me i
like you
just as you are
oh you had a thing on your cheek
your true self you're amazing on the
outside and the inside
is the fairest of them all
this is
[Music]
i shall return on tuesday
no wait let me check my calendar
thursday you got to be kidding me
red shoes and the seven dwarves
[Music]
basketball camp is next weekend you got
amazing potential on the court
and i can help you get there that's not
what i want dad
you never let me do what i want to do
you never let me just
do me hold up wrong floor
that will smith i gotta deal with this
what in the matrix hello
[Music]
welcome king james i am the king of this
domain
this is the server-verse what'd you do
to my son where's dom
the only way you're getting your son
back is if you and i play a little
basketball
pete send this clown to the rejects
what is this
i'm a cartoon what's up doc
i need to assemble an elite team to help
get my son back i know what you're
looking for
a dream team ma'am shoot the ball
let's try that again shall we
king james
welcome to the space jam
you gotta win this game let's end this
and get our son back
yikes
classic welcome to the space channel
i'm going old school on his butt
[Applause]
this is nothing
every family is weird but trust me
mine is the weirdest my dad
is bigfoot what's the next step clothing
line
sneaker endorsement video game deal yes
the bigfoot you wouldn't know it but
i'm a bigfoot too wow
extract oil puts nature first clean oil
by
extract clean oil you've got to be
kidding me
with your fame and influence you can
help stop extract before it's too late
you just got home you can't leave again
what's the point of fame if i don't use
it to make the world a better place
[Music]
why did extract need armed guards if
they've got nothing to hide
breaking news bigfoot has gone missing
what he needs our help
oh boy here we go again
hey guys buckle up so much for no
environmental impact
mom dad i'm the hero
they definitely noticed us what gave it
away mom don't sass your mother
hang on
let's finish this thing together
we're making pancakes hit me
oh shoot trapper don't thank me for your
lousy catch
all right guys remember what we're
looking for and don't
trust anyone
hey baby where are your parents
hey uh who's baby
really a con baby
[Music]
impressive we could use someone like you
let's catch you up
my name is raya our lands have been at
war for as long as we can remember
our people never see eye-to-eye
my daughter i believe our people can
come together again
but someone has to take the first step
now in order to restore peace
we must find the last dragon i wish to
join this fellowship of butt
hickory let's go
we'll have to watch our backs
we're not the only ones looking
six years of searching please let this
be it
almighty
we really need your help ah i'm gonna be
real with you i'm not like the best
dragon have you ever done like a group
project but there's like that one kid
who didn't pitch in as much but
still ended up with the same grade uh
we're doomed
you and the dragon are coming with me
hmm my sword here says we're not
the world's broken
you can't trust anyone
maybe it's broken because you don't
trust anyone
you just have to take the first step
i just changed dragons can do that look
how close my butt is to my
head it's gonna make digestion so much
faster
in theaters or ordered on disney plus
with premiere access
you are not going to get away with
good night good night dad
you're behind your dream stage it's
completely off limits for all dreamers
the dream stages are real wow you can
actually change people through their
dreams
why did they have to move in with us
don't you want to be a real family again
there's literally no insta here omg
omg my new stepsis come on selfie time
jenny has more than a thousand followers
that is so gross tomorrow i'll make sure
my mom removes that thing
i always get what i want three
two one don't wake me up she wants to
put my hamster in an animal shelter
maybe i could tinker a tiny little bit
with her dream
[Music]
so this will not end well
well that was a lot of shambles i mean
how am i supposed to whack in this heat
these conditions
[Music]
oh
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
disney and pixar seoul streaming on
disney plus december 25th
music is all i think about
from the moment i wake up in the morning
to the moment i fall asleep at night
i was born to play
it's my reason for living
[Applause]
hello
[Music]
a soul missing
is this heaven no is it h e
double hockey sticks how how hell quiet
coyote
no it's the great before this is where
new souls get their personalities
quirks and interest before they go to
earth here we are
don't worry you can't crush a soul here
that's what life on earth is for
whoa it's my life
can you help me get back come on
this won't be a disaster that's for sure
you're out these dummy little though
and i'm gonna find you
life is full of possibilities
you just need to know where to look
[Music]
don't miss out on the joys of life
like uh pizza i can't smell we can't
we can't taste either all that stuff is
in your body
no smell no taste or touch see
okay i get it disney and pixar's soul
get ready your life is about to start
start streaming december 25th peter
where's peter peter pizza peter rabbit
i'm starting to get worried
did you miss me wake up
we have a job to do i'm running there
tomorrow for cardio day
you can use your front legs too
let's have some fun
i don't know do you know what happens
after you eat too much sugar
that do you have any friends back home
can they be trusted
ah there's a couple i wouldn't let house
sit
[Music]
this is crazy
oh it's about to start you ready ready
popcorn
nachos see repair with red licorice
straw right here
maybe it's time we made our new movie
good idea scoob
but first we need a trailer oh can you
do the trailer guy voice
hmm well let me give it a
in a shot destroyed by evil
discover the epic origin story
of the greatest team of heroes
[Music]
nailed it
hey this mangy strays coming with me
he's not a stray
okay then what's his name his name's
scooby middle name last name
do
[Music]
like
uh maybe don't do that again
i'm fred this is velma hi and that's
daphne hey i'm shaggy
and this is scooby doo nice to meet you
trick or treat
whoa whoa whoa shaggy and scooby were
taken
do you realize where we are no look
around man
the clean modern aesthetic the cool blue
color palette
we're in did you say ikea nope
i said falcon terry just like you
maybe this can lead us to scooby and
shaggy trace amounts of mustache oil
12 year is old bad guy my
dad
[Music]
but it's time for shallow practice
but it's not holidays mom more time to
learn max and lana
are the best of friends if your mother
finds out let's go
you're dead when they meet the uglies
we're getting close now i can feel it
this place is perfect nothing but
wonderful
smelly rubbish the uglies eat rubbish no
wonder you don't want to dig in
there's no way we can eat this
there is a crisis in smellyville with
the stench from the local rubbish dump
tourism
at an all-time low it isn't just
tourists no one comes out much anymore
they seem to be some kind of natural
recyclers the uglies can save the town
just by being here
what these freaks have chosen the wrong
place to dig
their homes bye-bye rubbish dumb
hello wellness temple they want to build
a temple
right here it's where the uglies live
now
we'll have to leave again we can stop
that from happening this time
hammer is obviously up to something
let's follow and find out what
i will be so rich when we're done with
this town
gentlemen start your bulldozers
[Music]
come on ugly baby needs some proper
[Music]
[Music]
it was so food you came to town
welcome to smellyville
human power
they've taken control of most of europe
and russia
merciful heaven and invasion that's not
all mr president
i take it that's where your big idea
comes in let me introduce you the team
we said we would end this war
too many people have died
we can stop this
we need to utilize every meta human we
can
who you got there wonder woman i'm from
the future
it's not impossible
are you ready to end this war i thought
you'd never ask then welcome to the team
if this goes haywire blame the new guy
turns out the nazis are launching a
surprise attack then we stop them
mother of god
i kid you ain't seen nothing yet
happy birthday mr adult man oh my
god gross what was dad like
his beard was scratchy he had a goofy
laugh i wish i'd met him
i have something for you from your dad
it's a wizard staff
i wrote this spell so i could see for
myself who my boys grew up to be
this spell brings him back back like
back to life he wanted to meet you more
than anything
bully tooth of zadar how did you i don't
know it just started
hang on dad
stood up bart dad you are in your house
oh boy
we've only got 24 hours to bring back
the rest of dad
we're going on a quest
all quests start with the manticore the
fearless adventurer
you mean corey she's over there quick
somebody help me these griffin nuggets
were supposed to go out minutes ago
that's
the man's accord you guys are in trouble
big time
get in the vehicle i'm escorting you
home i'm giving you to the count of
three
[Music]
okay wait what are you doing i don't
know
i'm looking for my sons oh they went on
a quest but don't worry i told him about
the map
i told him about the gym i told him
about the curse huh i forgot to tell him
about the cars
what your boys are in grave danger
hold on
how are your boys doing a crisis oh no
we're dead we're dead we're dead not
great
i can't do it we're not gonna see you
dad you can do this
i believe in you my gut knows where to
go don't you boy
yes you do i am on my way boys
just stay out of trouble
[Music]
dancing
[Applause]
[Music]
erica you haven't ever wished a family
would adopt you
have you nope
anybody who choose me would be pretty
unusual
we'll take this one for the first time
in my life i'm being made to do
something i don't want to do
now then let's you and i get a few
things straight
my name is bella yaga i'm a witch
great you agree that you'll teach me
magic
and i agree to help you out if you work
really hard
i shan't do anything to hurt you
i love potion for the boy next door all
of these are pretty useless to me
the spell i believe you're looking for
is somewhere towards the back
hang on you actually talk of course i do
just not very often
in this household there's one rule
that's crucial
you must on no account for any reason
ever dare disturb the man drake
don't be
a witch rude only be filled by a witch
[Music]
i'll be learning magic well so i was
told can't wait to start
get up here you big lump no one must
know there are dragons in the battle
fire drake stay out of trouble what was
that
humans i've always told you they're the
worst what will they do when they find
them
the rim of heaven huh a paradise
for dragons we could go there and lead
everyone to safety how are you planning
to get that
i've got wings haven't i inspired by
cornelia funka's best-selling book
so genius where do we start
hi you're him
yeah climb aboard dragon rider
all humans are liars and chief you're a
fake you're not a dragon biter
[Music]
was that my pants yes
tell them who you are likes golf
and easy dragons
i just saw a juicy silver dragon
hunger
[Applause]
many have searched but no one has found
the rim of heaven who's hungry now's not
the time for refreshments i'm trying to
be mystical
it was an arranged marriage you are much
more than you think you are
follow your heart and the truth will
come to you ready
ready join a gang of unlikely friends
on a magical quest you want some of this
you
were a tiger
they're going
[Music]
coming soon candace every day you call
and tell me phineas and ferb have built
some big
unbelievable things and every day i come
home to find
nothing there doesn't it exhaust you
exhausts me
oh look there's nothing here
okay guys i give up what does this one
do
uh candace
where are you going where is she going
candace got abducted by aliens and taken
to another planet
when we step through this portal we're
gonna be on an alien planet
hello and welcome aliens giant robot
quick kiss that's just norm he's he's
usually
harmless if we're going to rescue kids
we need to build a spaceship like
galactic traveling
you mean like a spaceship but it's an
anethor there's a difference
it's branding leave me alone verb i know
we're gonna do today
we have to pass through an ion barrier
so it could fry all of the electronics
on the ship stopping us in space
okay that was something i did not know
we need to find where they're keeping
candice
[Music]
i know what we're gonna do today it's
me against the universe
[Music]
after a lifetime of being the world's
most famous enemies
you can't count on me like
one two three tom and jerry
are about to start over cause that's
what friends are supposed to do
[Music]
this hotel has been host to four
presidents three popes two kings and
we're about to host the wedding of the
century
do you think you're qualified to take on
this position i shine under pressure
like a diamond
or rihanna one other thing
we have a mouse problem with the what
now i'll catch it sir
everybody gonna shine
like this don't even gotta try oh wow
this is so detailed
we could hire an exterminator oh we can
leverage
millions of years of predatory evolution
if a picture of these mouse is tweeted
out to insta book face or
tiki talk we will be ruined no sir
that's not gonna happen
that rodent is toast
[Music]
i will not let this hotel be ruined by a
cat and a mouth
he's dying with us
i think i might have just pulled this
off really
in the bouncy house go about
remember what we talked about i don't
want to get a call from this new school
telling us that you've developed some
sort of chicken expanding rain
[Applause]
sorry about that
welcome to cranston academy look at this
place
from the creators of the nut job 2 and
escape from planet
earth i'd like to introduce you to danny
dawkins
thanks a lot genius danny dawkins is
about to discover
[Music]
another world well that was monumental
who are you i guess you can call me
mothman
what kind of alien language is that
there are monsters everywhere bulge was
getting bigger that means bigger
monsters can come out
how much bigger can they get
[Music]
oh get ready to fight the monsters
save the school if anyone can stop these
things it's the smartest kids in the
world
and be a hero you okay
i admit that plan wasn't fully thought
out featuring the voices of jamie bell
and ruby rose let's do this
monster zone you
didn't see nothing
i can't really be a lawyer and a
criminal can i
i want to win but do i want to win like
this
i'm of two minds here so it's a coin
flip
johnny vedi was murdered tonight falcone
crime family has to be taken down
[Music]
there's only room for one homicidal
maniac in this town
why are you running you could use a
little fun
i thought you didn't hurt people
you thought wrong
you still haven't figured out who killed
johnny fiti
a killer who only works on holidays
there's lots of crazy out there
once i take him out things are gonna be
different we can start a family
the city has fallen alfred and we must
endeavor to lift it up again
[Music]
who is holiday and who's next
[Music]
bye